Have you ever wondered if there was a secret to make eggs easy to peel?
If when you peel your eggs
you're taking more chunk of egg white off than you are shell,
then please listen. It doesn't really matter what type of egg you have.
If it's a chicken egg, a duck egg,
the colour of the egg and the thickness of the shell
also really doesn't make much difference.
You can put salt in when you're boiling.
You can boil for a short time or a long time.
You can also put your eggs in an ice bath after you boil them.
You might have already come across the secret to easily peeling eggs
without even realising it.
Have you ever peeled eggs and you felt wow,
this is really easy to peel eggs this time?
And then other times it just feels like an endless task
that's just not gonna work out.
So for this holiday season,
if you're making deviled eggs
and you really just want it that shell just to slide off perfectly,
then use old eggs. Now don't use expired eggs,
just use eggs that are older.
Fresh eggs just how the chickens.
But is not gonna peel well when hard boiled.
Now
most eggs that you get from the grocery store a few weeks old anyway.
Just use the oldest eggs you have this holiday season
and I promise you you will have an easy peeled egg.